Hogwarts Legacy has a ridiculous number
of customization options when it comes
to tweaking the look of your late 1800s
witch or wizard from Traditional School
robes to even spider-slayer armor
there's a wide range of options here for
players to choose from but which ones
are the best that's right today we're
ranking the top 10 outfits in Hogwarts
Legacy of course it's just my opinion
I'll tell you guys going in I don't
focus a lot on the glasses scarves or
hats if you're looking for a good hat
that kind of goes with a lot of
different things I would recommend the
classic sorcerer hat and then on some of
these I'll try and call out as we go
through what I think pairs well with it
so at number 10 we have the classical
school robe if you're someone who
prefers that traditional look for a
Hogwarts student then this is my
personal pick of the best one from the
list and there are surprisingly quite a
few variations of the school uniforms
and even quidditch uniforms the
classical school rope is a
well-appointed garment that combines
Timeless classical Style with
practicality I would pair it with the
prefix shirt and tie uniform and you'll
be ready to fully immerse yourself as a
student at Hogwarts I think it's best
worn without a hat or glove herbs and
because it's a robe you do always have
the option of wearing the hood up or
down at number nine it's the Kelpie robe
paired with the forest rivet gloves this
robe is a striking coat adorned and
emerald and gold featuring an animated
interpretation of the Majestic Water
Horse this enchanting robe embodies the
Allure and power of the mythical
creature evoking a sense of mystery and
Fascination it's also one of only two
robes in the entire game that featured
this Dynamic animation effect now
unfortunately the Kelpie robe is not
available to most players as the only
way to obtain it was by purchasing the
collector's edition of the game who
knows maybe at some point down the road
there'll be another way to unlock this
but right now that is the only way
number eight though is one that anybody
can obtain simply by solving Hogwarts
secrets we have the tailored tail coat
famously worn by Headmaster Phineas
nigellous black in the game and this is
a symbol of refined taste and dignified
Authority the legendary garment exudes
Flair and sophistication with its
meticulous tailoring and impeccable
attention to detail while no one would
confuse black as being a decent
Headmaster is no denying his sense of
style and what I love about this one is
that you have most of the look applied
without having to worry about any
additional pieces to mix and match
moving on to number seven we have the
treasure Seekers long coat this long
coat specially crafted for the
consummate Adventurer is earned by
successfully following a map to Hidden
Treasure it's a testament to players
determination and skill in uncovering
secrets and conquering challenges
complete with gloves a scarf and an
accompanying outfit this Ensemble is the
epitome of Adventure and exploration
there is also a hat option as well if
you want to go for that more seafaring
Voyager type of look for number six we
have the charms Professor set which was
only added to the game recently and
available for free through drops on
Twitch this set is highlighted by a
stylish and enchanting lavender robe
intricately trimmed in gold and green
the Garment draws inspiration from the
Beloved charms teacher and head of
Slytherin house Abraham Ronan
accompanying the robe is a set of
spectacles in lavender and gold
reflecting the playful nature of ronin
Additionally the scarf adds a touch of
charm and Whimsy to complete the
Ensemble and we can't forget the emerald
gloves with the serpentine to complete
the whole look now what's interesting
about this one is that Ronan in the game
didn't have the spectacles he didn't
have the scarf or even the gloves so the
team at Avalanche actually had to come
up with items that they thought could
potentially be worn by Ronan when he
wasn't in the castle teaching and I'd
say they nailed the look here now if you
take those gloves I think they will pair
very well with number five on our list
which was also available as a free
twitch drop it's Merlin's cloak this is
a legendary garment draped in Hues of
mystical blue and gold the cloak carries
with it the legacy of the mythical
wizard himself now despite the fact that
this was available as a free twitch drop
it was only possible by watching the
official Avalanche stream which really
helped to make this even more of a
sought out item by fans and even though
the green on the gloves doesn't quite
match up with the cloak I still think
it's fitting because Merlin himself was
a Slytherin also recommend wearing the
hood up and even though the outfit you
wear won't be seen much it does still
control the look of your pants and boots
so you'll want to set it to something
that you think matches up well and
number four it's the starry-eyed Sears
Ensemble this set is a captivating and
Celestial Ensemble that befits a master
astronomer earned through the discovery
of the astronomy tables in Hogwarts
Legacy this outfit cape and scarf come
together in a mesmerizing Celestial blue
each piece appears to have been crafted
to reflect the Wonder and vastness of
the night sky to complete the Ensemble I
gotta recommend the ashwinder skull
gloves because they align perfectly with
the overall theme here and with that we
have reached the top three of the best
outfits in Hogwarts Lexi and before we
get to those I have to give a quick
honorable mention to the Spider Slayer
armor it's not one that I personally
used a lot but I love the fact that they
included Off the Wall sets like this and
you could probably put something like
the dress robes inspired by Ron Weasley
from the original series in that same
category as well now speaking of the
original series if you'd ever like to
relive it you can actually get a free
audiobook that's yours to keep forever
thanks to today's sponsor audible.com
all you have to do is go to
audibletrial.com Retro to sign up for a
free 30-day trial you'll receive one
credit that's good for any Premium
Selection titles you prefer and again
you keep the audiobook even if you
cancel the trial so it's basically like
a free audiobook of your choice you also
get two credits if you're an Amazon
Prime member and they'll even send you a
friendly reminder email before the trial
ends continuing on with our list though
it's the dark arts cosmetic set this
Ensemble is designed for those who
possess a proclivity for pushing the
boundaries of magic I mean in a game
with all three unforgivable curses you
gotta have something for those dark
Wizards to wear right and this Ensemble
is absolutely designed for those who
possess a proclivity for pushing the
boundaries of magic it's obtained by
purchasing the deluxe edition of the
game or the dark arts cosmetic pack
add-on the centerpiece of this set it
has to be that animated row featuring
the skulls that really add an eerie yet
captivating element to the whole set so
this and the Kelpie robe only two sets
in the game that feature some sort of
animation on the attire there's also a
scarf Black Rivet gloves and a Garrison
hat that adds a touch of Edge and
sophistication the dark arts Ensemble is
tailor-made for those who see great
power regardless of the cost and serves
as a visual representation of their
unyielding determination to explore the
depths of magical possibility but when I
should point out there is a dark arts
mask as well honestly though overall I'm
not really a fan of many of the masks in
the game but it is nice that they're
there if you want to go with an even
more Sinister kind of look for number
two we have the house Relic uniforms
this is a prestigious garment to proudly
showcase the identity and spirit of your
Hogwarts house each robe is carefully
designed to depict the mascot and colors
associated with your house serving as a
visual representation of Your Allegiance
and pride these uniforms are earned by
unlocking your house chest using the
elusive to daily and keys so while it
takes a while to hunt down all those
keys it is definitely a worthwhile
Pursuit this was actually my top pick
for quite a long time I still think it's
really good it was so close to being
number one but I just can't put it all
the way at the top because it's only a
single piece of gear you'll have to mix
and match other pieces with it to find
what you think is the best look it's
going to be slightly different based on
which house you're in I think for both
Gryffindor and Slytherin it goes pretty
well with something like the legendary
armored attire if it just had its own
matching outfit though I think that
might have been enough for me to keep it
at the top spot oh and one final bit of
flair that I just love is that soft glow
that flashes each time you cast a spell
while wearing it this actually makes it
the only Cosmetic in the game that has a
feature like this and at number one we
have a set that truthfully I barely
notice on my first playthrough I think
maybe because it's rather hard to obtain
but it's not until I went back to make
this video that I saw how awesome
herodiana's attire can be this Ensemble
is inspired by herodiana the famed
depulso Master herself to earn it you'll
have to solve all of the depulso puzzles
in the Hall of herodiana and it's
certainly no easy task to complete those
the highlight of the attire has to be
the cape which looks so great with the
hood up there are some capes in the game
that don't have a hood at all but
fortunately this one does honestly this
looks like a set that could be pulled
right out of something like Zelda or
even Assassin's Creed to complete the
Ensemble the treasure seeker's gloves I
think are a great option to really bring
together The Adventurous look so what
are your favorite outfits in Hogwarts
Legacy have you found all of those to
daily and keys yet if not I've got the
perfect video ready for you that will
make it super easy to find all the keys
and you'll be able to unlock your house
Relic uniforms in no time I'll link it
here on the right side of the screen now
as always guys thank you all so much for
watching I'll talk to you again soon